oui
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de la grande interview notre invité est
installé dans un autre studio dans le
centre de paris à l'abri des risques
sanitaires notre invité cette semaine
pierre gagnaire merci d'être là pierre
gagnaire bonjour vous êtes heureux vous
présente pas vous êtes une des stars de
la de la gastronomie française à 3
étoiles au michelin un établissement
phare à paris que beaucoup connaissent
rue balzac depuis 1996 je crois et vous
avez construit parallèlement un cas un
groupe quasi mondiale puisque votre nom
figure à peu près sur le fronton des
restaurants dans une dizaine ou dans une
quinzaine de capital de la planète
pierre gagnaire vous êtes quasiment au
chômage depuis presque un an maintenant
qu'est ce qui se passe dans la tête
quand on est ce que vous êtes sans avoir
la possibilité d'exercer
j'allais dire votre armée c'est aussi
votre métier votre raison de vivre
d'abord avant d'avoir un peu de succès
j'ai eu un gros échec à saint etienne
puisque effectivement la cuisine de la
vie la vie plutôt comme un artiste pas
comme un entrepreneur ni comme un homme
nu comme un homme d'affaires donc j'ai
construit en fait mon projet
professionnel dans une ville que j'aime
qui s'appelle saint etienne mais où le
la clientèle n'était pas là et donc 96
déjà c'était l'époque un peu compliqué
il ya eu des grandes grèves qui avaient
bloqué le pays pendant quelques semaines
une situation locale qui était difficile
donc voyons que j'aurai des difficultés
à exercer mon métier comme je
l'imaginais j'ai donc décidé de me
saborder mais sa bande et ça veut dire
tout perdre
donc pour moi cette cette période a été
extrêmement douloureuse mais elle m'a
véritablement permis de 2
de rebondir et et de prendre le risque
de devenir dans une à paris qui était
qui et quand même la capitale de
peut-être bon dial de dudu dudule de cet
art de vivre que tout le monde nous
envie et je dois dire que lorsque c'est
arrivé cette histoire d'abord d'abord
comme nous tous
moi j'ai plein plein de connaissances
dans le milieu médical personne ne
prenait pas au sérieux et nous notre
restaurant à shanghai déjà fermé et on
nous alertait mais on était c'était loin
et en fait quand on est un peu d'hommes
du monde comme je suis on sait très bien
que le monde aujourd'hui est un on est
tous on est tous les liens liés les uns
aux autres la planète lcl s'est
considérablement rétrécie
grâce aux moyens de communication les
ventes tout ce qu'on connaît
voilà mais on était dans notre petite
bulle et tout le monde y annonce il n'y
a pas de problème quoi et puis le
problème est arrivé donc moi au départ
j'ai vécu un peu comme une période
presque béni de repos parce que depuis
des effectifs mans depuis depuis toutes
ces années je travaillais au moment je
voyage beaucoup ge à la fois jeu
j'essaie de manier à la fois l'aspect
quelques heures de ma vie artistique et
puis et puis j'ai compris que c'était
aussi un business et qu'il fallait qu'il
fallait faire faire tourner la boutique
quoi comme on dit un voilà donc c'est
aussi j'étais dans une haie jour je me
tais pas perdu mais je sais je
travaillais beaucoup beaucoup donc cette
période était le premier confinement ça
fait d'abord un espèce de relâchement
total de comme beaucoup de gens
d'ailleurs qui ont des responsabilités
un peu de sidération médias et côté j'y
peux rien c'est pas de ma faute j'ai
donc comme c'est quand on est
responsable et qu'on est que si huit
noms semblent plus maître de son temps
et là il ya une espèce de sentiment
presque 2 2
de repos qu'on peut dire et puis là
maintenant les deuxièmes confiance
qu'elle même se passer là là c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué parce que parce
que effectivement moi j'ai jamais pensé
que ça partirait comme ça tout le monde
s'agite moment du parle du monde de
demain tout le monde allait à la rentrée
au mois de septembre tout va que tout
ira bien
2021 arrive à l'essayer c'est beau non
non c'est pas comme ça que ça marche
c'est bien là aujourd'hui 1 il ya
quelque chose de profond qui n'est pas
maîtrisable les le monde entier pendant
je retiens une phrase que j'ai entendu
au début d'un du confinement que
quelqu'un disait c'est la première fois
dans l'humanité que les dirigeants
politiques met l'homme au centre du
terrain et les ombres à sauver l'homme
donc alors bien sûr je pense que
derrière ça y est peut être des raisons
un peu peut-être électoralistes
peut-être aussi de toute façon ça durant
quelques semaines
et puis on va repartir ça va repartir et
puis ça repart pas elle est
effectivement tournées pris au piège
parce que parce que parce que
effectivement une société qui est à
l'arrêt depuis un an c'est une espèce de
glissades où personne ne sait où on va
aller on peut dire pour l'instant
soutien ya pas qu à gagnières vous vous
réagissez ou pas comme beaucoup de chefs
d'entreprise qui qui reconnaissent que
les choses tiennent c'est à dire que les
actifs de production n'ont pas été
détruits il n'y a pas eu de bombardement
n'y a pas eu
il n'y a pas une destruction n'y a pas
eu de dégâts matériels
oui mais il ya eu des dégâts dans la
tête quand même psychologiques non voilà
bah oui clairement mais c'est trop tôt
pour faire un bilan de cette histoire
voyez j'ai j'ai un ami qui m'a envoyé un
message hier soir une manip pierre nous
vivons une apocalypse molle et je trouve
que c'est un mois c'est assez bien vu
c'est tout
tout est un peu ralenti tout un et
effectivement ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est quand on se bat dans les rues de
paris canton d'uri
rien n'a changé quoi tout tout tout est
là et puis on dit attention protégez
vous de votre voisin protégez-vous des
postillons protégez-vous le somali les
rampants mais pour l'instant quand même
je parle de vue du côté français un dans
tous les cas je trouve que ça tient et
on peut on peut quand même rendre
hommage à nos institutions quand même
parce que tout le monde râle ceci cela
le barça va trop vite pas assez vite
pour vacciner pas vacciner m'enfin bon
pour l'instant c'est je pense qu'on est
là on est dans un moment où on peut pas
on peut pas tirer de bilan je crois est
un peu juste par les exprimer les
sentiments
oui mais pierre gagnaire quand on est
comme vous vous êtes pas seulement le
chef d'un restaurant mais vous êtes des
chefs d'entreprise vous avez des
salariés
vous avez des responsabilités vous avez
des charges vous avez des loyers vous
avez tout ça oui sur le plan économique
vous considérez avoir été aidé
suffisamment pendant combien de temps
encore pouvez vous tenir
c'est marrant la question je me la pose
pas je baille frais il faudrait que il
faudrait qu'il faudrait quand même une
cale il faudrait que dans trois mois les
choses soient à peu près rentré dans
l'ordre moi j'ai l'agent si vous voulez
d'avoir pris le risque de deux d'avoir
d'autres d'autres activités
effectivement que mes trois propre
restaurant parisien
il est évident que le restaurateur qui a
eu lieu qui n'a pas d'activité à côté je
pense que tout aux dépens de tout dépend
de l'attitude des pouvoirs publics
si on ne continue de payer
les salariés qu'on vous aide au niveau
des charges qu'on arrivait à faire des
petits report de loyer fin ça peut tenir
encore quelques mois bien évidemment
mais j'ose espérer qu'on mais je suis
j'ai pas de qu'on n'est pas au bord de
l'apocalypse
pour l'instant c'est pour l'instant
c'est pas le cas voilà alors qu'à
gagnaire je les regarde mais dernière
vous vous vous êtes installé je le
disais tout à l'heure dans le monde
entier un vous êtes à hong kong je crois
shanghai vous êtes à las vegas aux états
unis comment vous vous voyez dans le
monde la capacité de résilience est ce
qu'elle est meilleure qu'en france ou
pas comment ça marche en asie comment ça
marche aux états unis aux etats unis la
la sega s'est formée de plat pour le
confirmer dès maintenant
ouais les les jambes un classique à
l'américaine vous rentrez chez vous
votre ordinateur reste dans bureau vous
êtes vous devenez le
vous êtes presque un par yole de
l'entreprise donc vous n'ait plus droit
de parler avoue ne plus revenir aussi
dans votre lieu de travail ou n'aient
plus droit dehors de contact donc
c'était terrible parce que là les gens
ne sont pas payés l'est pas je vous
connaissais ça bien mieux pourquoi
monsieur sylvestre et donc la suisse et
ses terribles un viol il ya là bien la
violence le leur en plus de tout ce qui
se passe en ce moment au niveau critique
donc donc à las vegas tout tout et à
tout est à l'arrêt à 90%
c'était terrible à shanghai par exemple
bas il ya eu des des mesures drastiques
qui ont été prises
on voit bien façon asiatique quoi c'est
que ce soit d'ailleurs la tokyo que ce
soit
que ça soit hong kong où que ce soit
shanghai il ya d'édition qui sont prises
des gens doivent rester chez eux
voilà il ya tout un c'est à dire vous
avez sont très directive vous avait
réouvert les restaurants de deux
s'engagent en son nom oui charest bah
oui je reviendrai oui oui mais il marche
très très bien
oui j'avais il marche très très bien
encore hong kong
mon contrat se terminait donc le long
combat là le lab ont contraint c'est le
hasard a fait que mon contrat s'arrêtait
il ya quelques il ya quelques semaines
donc la longue ça ferme sa ouvre mais
banon comme jonnier plus c'est terminé
las vegas c'est terrible pour le coup
vous êtes à dubaï alors voyez on à dubaï
lors dubaï dubai
il ya des gars au south sa ferme
aujourd'hui à dubaï repart bien peu il
ya beaucoup de gens beaucoup de gens
vont à dubaï effectivement fait beau les
infrastructures de qualité et donc sa
mort dubai marche bien londres vous à
l'orientale andrew landreau londres ben
alors l'endroit est fermé
londres c'est un peu le yoyo fermé
ouvert fermé là ce qui se passe à
londres
c'est bien plus grave quand bien plus
grave qu'en fonçant au niveau sanitaire
ouais à titre personnel vous avez réussi
à faire le tour de vos restaurants
depuis le début de la crise ou pas non
non non c'est le plus difficile parce
que d'abord d'abord ces visites 1 parce
que parce qu'effectivement
de façon arbitraire mes partenaires ne
me paie plus donc bon donc je comme je
veux préserver l'avenir j'allais pas je
vais pas rentrer dans des polémiques des
histoires qui servira à rien et dans
tous les cas
d'abord je n'ai pas construit un empire
je suis quelqu'un qui a un mode avec ce
qui m'est arrivé il ya 25 ans il ya
trente ans j'aime j'aime fonctionnement
personnel assez modeste donc ça sale
sale sale fait et puis et puis les gens
avec qui je travaille je m'entends bien
avec eux je mets à leur place et je
préserve l'avenir et je me dis que voilà
on se remettre autour de la table dans
dans quelques mois l'année prochaine et
que et que l'histoire que les histoires
continueront à la maison je suis pas
dans un mode polémique que je n'ai pas
les moyens et 2 sommes atterrés sport
s'est pas montrée l'hôpital avec un
cancer ce qui me fera bien gagnaire
qu'on sait c'est bon c'est votre sourire
mais c'est aussi l'absence de
découragement que que vous avez cette
formidable capacité de de résilience
depuis 30 ans dont vous faites preuve
ces produits est une énorme leçon dans
un petit instant parce qu'on va parler
de la suite est justement la façon dont
vous voyez l'abolir maintenant parce que
j'ai l'impression
vous y avez beaucoup réfléchir on se
retrouve dans trois minutes
[Musique]
au tour sur le plateau de la grande
interview avec pierre gagnaire le
restaurateur trois étoiles paris rue
balzac qui évidemment un peu désoeuvrés
mais pas découragés ils nous l'avaient a
parlé pendant la première partie avant
de voir comment vous vous imaginer
l'avenir et comment vous le vous le
préparez pierre gagnaire j'avais une
question à vous poser parce que votre
métier votre succès c'est évidemment
votre talent votre imagination
mais c'est aussi un grand sens de
l'organisation moi j'ai été frappée en
visitant vos cuisines de l'extrême
propreté de l'extrême organisation qui
pouvait y avoir dans vos établissements
c'est un c'est un spectacle qui réglé au
millimètre a par rapport à tout ça
comment vous jugez maintenant la façon
dont on a géré la crise qui a quand même
donné l'impression d'une énorme
improvisation notamment en france je ne
mettrai pas de juger je peux pas juif il
ya des ya des choses qu'on ne sait pas
il ya des ja ce qui est évident ma
petite expérience me fait dire quand
même que les les
la ministre mais j'avais pathak
administration l'administration samson
au sens large du terme dirt 2 mai dans
une entreprise des bureaux d iliad
espèce de aujourd'hui le mail est
tellement est tellement facile on envoie
un mail aux instances de base du 11e 11
et base du problème
voilà il ya tellement de gens que lui
mais c'est c'était pas mal c'est pas moi
c'est pas moi c'est pas moi c'est acquis
quant au moins ce qui me prend beaucoup
quand je regardais la télévision et je
veux dire que je suis comme tout le
monde je me laisse happer par eux parce
zapping continue de gens qui passent sur
les plateaux et je sus un je suis frappé
par le nombre de présidents de de gens
qui ont des titres ronflants et qui
contredisent
alors alors alors mai mais ces jeux on
peut pas juger de façon
de façon agressive ces situations elle
est tellement elle est tellement bizarre
une nouvelle que que chacun sans se
raccroche à un bout de rocher avec son
petit bout de vérité alors mais c'est
sûr qu'il ya des dysfonctionnements dans
les plus que moi je vis dans au sein des
choses un peu plus importante avec
lesquels je avec les gens et qui se
travaille on voit bien qu'il ya des
déperditions d'énergie qui sont
terrifiantes c'est pourquoi nous on est
fonctionne bien parce qu'on est petit on
est réactif on est agile on est au mois
mai mais georges et connais je les vois
sur scène
enfin je resserre la main je refais le
guet et ont quelques instants règle un
problème quoi oui laganière vous vous
faites preuve là de votre optimisme et
puis de votre sens de l'organisation
votre débrouillardise finalement
collective de travail qu'en est il des
gens qui travaillent avec vous notamment
en amont vos fournisseurs par exemple
ils ont trouvé des solutions
alternatives ou pas il y en a qui sont
débrouillards d'autres qui le sont moins
ouais euh et puis le premier contact
avec cette réalité c'était c'était au
des quelques semaines après le
après c'est ce confinement c'est au
moins d'avril et il ya une femme qui y
est un petit élevage de pigeons avec qui
on travaille et des sens l'odeur à
malmedy pierre il faut m'aider je vais
devoir battre mais mes bêtes
voilà faut que je trouve une solution
bon alors on a pouvait le trouver une
solution je l'étais baline il m'a appelé
et la sole ou tarp et d'autres d'autres
cuisiniers qui travaillait avec elle
donc qu elle a réussi par par le biais
de
justement de traiteur de boucher a
réussi à vendre à vendre ses magnifiques
pigeon écoulé est donc aujourd'hui
effectivement il ya plein de moyens de
l'autre jour j'ai vu une image qui m'a
terrifiant de 2 le père et le fils dans
le cantal qui ont qui aurait les ventes
du lait oeufs le lait qui s'est collé et
quand ans et qui ces couleurs les dents
bien la rigole dans la ferme et moi ça
ça sent terrifie parce que parce que
cette image je l'associé à des enfants
qui meurent de faim des enfants qui
n'ont pas de quoi qu'ils n'ont pas le
petit verre de lait qui va les sauver
donc c'est c'est aussi tout un
questionnement sur la société sur le
rapport à la solidarité à ce
dysfonctionnement qui que je comprends
pas personnellement je sais pas j'ai pas
les clés mon jeu je produis je travaille
je sais c'est de faire au mieux dans mon
dans ma gestuelle quotidienne et aidant
les gens qui m'entourent j'essaie de
d'être le plus le plus aisément possible
je dirais à quelles conditions pires
gagna allons nous pouvoir ré ouvrir les
restaurants est ce qu'on va vous
demander est-ce que vous êtes prêts à
accepter un renforcement des conditions
sanitaires un renforcement de la
distanciation par exemple s'il ya des
solutions
non mais vous vous avez répondu vous
avez vous m'avez donné la réponse tout à
l'heure donc nos cuisines au mois mai
trois restaurants à paris on est les
amoureux de la qualité et je hais je
parle au nom de tout et de tous mes
confrères restaurateurs qui sont dans le
même registre que moi on est des gens on
passe ton temps récurer les coins on
pense au temps nettoyer les toilettes on
passe notre temps à faire la poussière
on passe le temps à récurer les cuivres
qui sont toujours à et insolents on le
le le le samedi soir on est derrière on
nettoie les fourneaux nouveau tourner
donc on est non il n'y a pas de problème
chez nous y sommes
on peut s'il est l'antre passé peut-être
en test au départ à l'entrée lorsqu'ils
arrivent mais nos noms prerure demain
c'est pas nous qui allons mettre qu'elle
en voudra pas dire d'aller dans les
dents
dans les yeux dans les yeux d'un clic
alors alors pardonnez moi mais est-ce
que vous allez demander avec certains
d'autres de vos confrères notamment
l'obligation d'avoir un test avant de
venir au restaurant ou même le passeport
vaccinale dans la mesure où tout le
monde
la plupart où la majorité seraient
vaccinés moi je suis pas quelqu'un de
jeu
je suis pas un leader syndical
ces jeux c'est pas mon truc bon c'est un
métier c'est un c'est une forme de il ya
une réflexion à voir qu'il est très
profonde avec des relations avec l'ue
lobbies donc mais il ya eu il ya nos
pieds il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
combien pris les choses en main mais je
pense que on est et c'est presque
inévitable que l'on met tout le monde
dans le même panier et à dire que la
boîte de nuit le bistrot de quartier qui
roule gens s'entassent voilà donc il ya
peu on peut pas sectorisé quoi on peut
pas mettre des catégories parce que déjà
nous on pense déjà approuvé pour des
gens qui servent donc les riches ce qui
est complètement faux d'ailleurs on est
on pouvait déjà dans une
on est déjà dans on est des gens
comprennent pas les prix qu'on pratique
donc se replier sur plan idéologique et
politique on peut pas revenir dans we
may vous vous y voilà vous avez trois
étoiles 2 étoiles vous êtes là vous êtes
à part vous êtes des bons élèves
ces peuples c'est pas possible c'est pas
possible mais des questions très
précises et très concrètes
est ce que vous demanderez à vos
salariés de vous de se faire vacciner
par exemple est ce que vous aimez mais
oui vous allez vous faire vacciner vous
à bas mot des abats 1,3 fois s'il faut
un
évidemment oui bien évidemment c'est pas
forcément évident pour tout le monde
vous savez pierre gagnaire actuellement
et moi je sais je sais moche dit
évidemment oui je sais je suis quelqu un
légaliste et pour d'abord d'abord ya
déjà eu des tests qui ont été faits et
donc été vaccinées personnes s'est
transformée en cheval est ce que vous
pensez qu'on va revenir à la vie d'avant
notamment par rapport à vos restaurants
ou
qui va y avoir des choses ils vont
changer je vous donne un seul exemple le
télétravail le télétravail est peut-être
la raréfaction des grands voyages
touristiques dans le monde
ça va quand même diminué une partie de
votre clientèle alors ça c'est la bonne
question
si tu es tout le monde s'accorde à dire
que le l'activité reprendre ses voyages
on prendra pas avant peut-être deux
trois ans là ça va être ça va être un
vrai problème
je pense que ben il y aura de la casse
peut-être que je serai dans les gens qui
partiront la poubelle ne sais pas il
restera des bourses y restera des beaux
restaurants
il reste parce que ça fait partie du 2 2
ça fait partie de nos jours dit il
associe du d'une sociabilité des d'autre
de notre monde je dirais
opulente faut le dire quand même un lait
et donc ils n'ont les restaurants vont
rester après effectivement le vrai
problème et c'est là et là vraiment
j'espère vraiment que pour le coup les
choses vont s'accélérer
parce que le monde a besoin de se
connaître
le monde a besoin de manger la chance
depuis maintenant vingt ans de faire des
choses incroyables partout et j'ai
rencontré des gens que des gens
extraordinaires et on se rend compte que
l'homme qu'ils habitent là ou là ou là
il ya des gens fiers des gens à leur
travail
alae et le que le et depuis le commerce
c'est le commerce et le sait le lien
entre dans le monde
je plains pierre gagnaire j'entends bien
votre votre plaidoirie la très émouvante
enfin ça en faveur finalement dû de la
mondialisation quelque part mais cette
mondialisation elle elle est critiquée
on lui fait sur le procès aussi de ces
exagérations
est ce que vous pensez vous qu'elle
aboutit à une égalisation une
uniformisation des modes de vie
notamment dans votre domaine
je ne saisis pas bien votre question la
non non ce qui l'est mondialisation
n'est pas moi je je je je prends souvent
l'exemple de la vache folle la vache
folle c'est pour des raisons voilà on
veut on veut que tout le monde mange du
fier de boxe épicier de boeuf bas il
faut comme on vous le vendre à un prix
raisonnable 20 alors bien et donc ça
cbre excite c'est léger jaune
c'est cette douleur de gens qui sont
laissés sur chemins c'est le bleu le
profit extrême à tout prix sans c'est le
sait le sujet
de notre monde aujourd'hui sur quelque
chacun de réfléchir et réfléchir et
justement quand on a la chance d'être
chef d'entreprise on peut agir bien sûr
très modestement mais concrètement
moi je je je je je je je dirais je les
gens qui m'accompagnent
ils sont ils sont c'est l'ordre lors de
mon histoire c'est pas la carotte qui
est un porc à la carotte est importante
mais l'important c'est l'homme
c'est lui qui est qui et qui crée le
cette chose unique qui est le ce sourire
c'est de ce service que l'on offre aux
gens oui mais vous avez répondu c'était
sens de ma question sur la sueur sur la
mondialisation
vous allez faire la cuisine aujourd'hui
ce midi vous allez vous mettre aux
fourneaux ou pas oui oui oui pour vous
votre famille leurs amis
j'ai la chance folle non non je vais on
a deux restaurants à paris qui sont
ouverts qui vont l'emporter
le restaurant il a dit oui c'est pas
extraordinaire mais ça crée du lien et
aujourd'hui je vais aller dans le
restaurant italien
et enfin on a reçu quelques truffes et
on me faire je vais en faire un peu de
topinambours
l'une all in avec les truffes et et
comme ces jeunes gens savent quoi faire
je vais je vais faire trois kilos de
topinambours dans une belle cocotte que
je veux que j'ai acheté hier soir et on
va cuisiner en ce moment là et plus de
trois bricoles haute ou non mais je je
je suis encore avec mes gants cuisine
parce qu'on a ces lieux qui sont qui
effectivement sont ouverts ouais
laganière merci beaucoup merci pour
cette leçon de d'optimisme et et surtout
cette leçon d'énergie que vous avez et
que vous et que vous portez là que vous
en voyez
voilà merci mille fois l'émission et je
voulais ça peut repartir à vos cuisines
parce que je sais bien que s'il ya que
là que vous n'êtes que vous êtes heureux
l'émission est terminée on la retrouve à
l'antenne bien sûr la retrouve en
rediffusion la retrouve en replay sur
les réseaux sociaux on la retrouve sur
le site internet bien sûr
rt france point tv pierre gagnaire merci
encore à très bientôt
[Musique]